[Música]
meu nome é leandro e ia começar contando
pra vocês uma história na minha infância
eu adorava colorir desenhos né
mas não é qualquer tipo de desenho e
desenhos específicos feitos pelos meus
tios né
certa vez fui pedir para um deles teria
que fazer um desenho para tal
por algum motivo ele não pode fazer né
eu meu aujali dos nove anos
voltei pra casa fui lá pra minha mãe
então mãe não conseguiu desenhar natal
fiquei muito triste ali enchendo ela ela
foi pegou o papel assim tira da minha
mão foi lá fez o desenho top olhei assim
né
só que não desenho a qualidade feita
pelos tios né da pro colorir qualquer
tipo de desenho
ela olhou pra mim e falou então se você
não gostou porque você mesmo não tenta
até então eu nunca tinha tentado mesmo
fazer um desenho daquele nível só fazia
desenhos infantis
falei poxa isso começando levar um
pouquinho mais a sério e se eu começar a
tentar copiando os traços meus filhos
fazem
fui várias vezes tentei tentei dar
errado e saía feio até chegou um ponto
que eu conseguir fazer um eu lembro que
naquela época no colégio acho que todo
mundo teve aquela pessoa que era o
desenhista da sala
vocês já viram alguma coisa assim eu
acabei me tornando esse cara desista das
aulas
então qualquer coisa relacionada à
criatividade acaba sempre caindo pra mim
foi muito legal eu comecei há realmente
me senti um desenho
só que aí
o errava igual os meus tios né
passou-se o tempo aqui na graduação como
falou não faz tanto tempo assim
eu estava na graduação eu era presidente
de uma empresa júnior aquele semestre
foi um dos mais difíceis que eu já
passei
talvez alguns de vocês aí se
identifiquem um pouco conforme vou
falando né
minha vida social de vida social não
existia praticamente não tinha tempo pra
nada dentro da própria empresa junã a
minha liderança ceia horrível não
conseguia bater nenhuma meta não
conseguiu engajar as pessoas naquilo que
eu propunha então realmente é uma coisa
muito complicada para mim e na graduação
espero que vocês não se identifiquem com
isso seis matérias só tem uma
foi um momento muito drástico pra mim
porque aparentemente tudo aquilo que
fazia não estava dando certo
chegou o ponto que eu recebi um e-mail
que estava escrito no perfil de
desligamento
eu precisava falar com o professor a
respeito disso
fui até ele numa sala conversar com ele
lá ele me perguntou uma série de coisas
e aí como é que a sua vida tal está com
algum problema pessoal familiar se há
alguma doença
falei não tem nenhum problema é talvez
por eu estar levando a graduação junto
com a empresa júnior é uma coisa
a partida foi muito pesado e eu sou
presidente lá realmente está difícil e
ele me aconselhou
talvez seja melhor você sair da empresa
júnior porque está atrapalhando a sua
graduação
eu acho que alguns de vocês já ouviram
essas frases nesse momento comecei a me
questionar se eu tava no curso certo
será que eu realmente estou fazendo
aquilo que deveria está fazendo
será que ele está certo quando ele
afirma que é melhor eu sair é normal na
vida a gente tem essas dúvidas é muito
comuns
o grande problema é quando nessas
dúvidas a gente vai procurar uma solução
mágica
o jeito certo o passo a passo até então
eu fiquei muito em dúvida me
pressionando bastante e decidir
novamente tentar se aquela criança que
tentou na época dela fazer atividades
complexas e chegou até hoje aqui deu
tudo certo porque não tentar novamente
então comecei a minha jornada de como
ser um líder autêntico quem puder ou
quiser alguma anotação mentais quiser eu
aconselho que vocês a nota em algumas
idéias que você diria para vocês
então eu não sabia e alto líder a perder
o controle da minha vida
aparentemente então a primeira coisa que
eu deveria aprender é auto liderança
como é que eu vou desafiar as pessoas se
nem eu mesmo me desafiava vamos começar
pela liderança mas para começar a auto
liderar
eu nunca tinha tempo seria interessante
então se eu começasse a organizar meu
tempo
então esse é o passo 1 organizar o tempo
conversei com uma série de pessoas
procurem muitas referências livros
podcast tudo tentei fazer inversão em
cada coisa que eu colocava o primeiro
ponto organizar o tempo segundo ponto é
a palavra muito com qualquer coisa
o feedback já negativo era uma coisa
ruim uma resposta negativa eu já me
senti um pouco abalado a própria
conversa com o professor quando ele
duvidava de mim já me senti um pouco
abalado
seria ele e seria interessante então eu
procurar alguma forma de lidar com isso
talvez inteligência emocional então
segundo ponto e inteligência emocional
eu queria um pouco mais ainda me sentir
falta um pouco mais de segurança
então eu comecei a ver outros modelos eu
comecei a ver um dos líderes
muita gente até profissional daqui mesmo
do próprio ted eu vi eles precisam como
eles falavam cada pedaço
eu comecei a perceber que eu precisava
assim como antes eu acreditava que era
um desenhista talvez acreditar que eu
era o líder também então eu passei no
terceiro ponto acreditar que era um
líder
no quarto ponto eu já me sentia seguro
pra falar
a equipe da equipe que eu liderava na
época que era da empresa júnior
então agora eu acho que seria
interessante começar a treinar um pouco
mais a comunicação porque não tem
engajado muito bem eles então o quarto
ponto seria comunicação efetiva com o
time
no quinto eu queria que eles se
sentissem como eu me sentia por ser
presidente eu me sentia muito dono
daquilo eu queria que eles também se
sentissem a mesma coisa só que como
fazer isso
um chute que eu tinha era talvez uma
cultura organizacional
só que eu não precisava mais procurar
sozinho e se eu jogasse para eles pouco
a gente faz para aprender a cultura
organizacional e um deles me sugeriu uma
outra pessoa que sabia muito a respeito
de cultura organizacional é isso que a
gente acaba aprendendo organizacional
bom
recapitulando cinco pontos então
organizar o tempo de licença emocional
comunicação
aliás acreditar ser o líder o quarto
ponto comunicação e o quinto cultura
organizacional certo
bom então é isso gente isso é a
liderança autêntica né
acho que o silêncio de vocês conseguem
responder que obviamente que não vai
obter a sua autêntica autenticidade é
aquilo que é legítimo que é verdadeiro
eo que é real
como vocês vão aprender liderança
autêntica
se você está seguindo o mesmo modelo
lembra quando falei do jeito certo
essa idéia tudo isso que eu pedi pra
vocês notarem joga fora
rasga tira embaralha adiciona coisas
festa vocês mesmos
a idéia não é vocês seguirem a minha
experiência a minha história que eu
contei isso não é ser autêntico
isso você é você sendo uma fraude
seguindo alguém copiando alguém
o problema disso de você tentar seguir
outros modelos é que você vai sentir uma
fraude
você vai se sentir seguro nas suas
atividades
para vocês terem noção como isso é
pesado
eu vou fazer um teste bem rápido
todos vocês estão sentados certo vocês
têm certeza que vocês estão sentados do
jeito certo
todo mundo certo está correta a coluna
no momento em que eu falo isso eu vejo
algumas cabeças assim se mexer um
pouquinho
você percebe que foi plantado uma certa
dúvida em vocês
será que eu estou fazendo do jeito certo
troca esse cenário coloca a liderança
será que você está liderando jeito
correto você percebe o estresse elevado
só por eu sugeri que talvez você não
esteja seguindo o modelo exato
só que não é essa idéia da autenticidade
à liderança autêntica é criado pela
experiência de vocês
a vivência de vocês o que eu acredito na
liderança autêntica é que você precisa
ter uma base forte uma mentalidade muito
forte ea partir daí os seus propósitos
as suas experiências vão fazer você ser
um líder autêntico você vai passar
vergonha
você vai ficar embaraçoso vários
momentos mas você vai aprendendo cada um
desses momentos a gente tem medo de
falhar mas é nesse momento que vai
acabar aprendendo então
eu acabei retomando minha vida eu
consegui aprender é a lidar com a
graduação ea empresa de energia
comecei a ter mais tempo eu fui reeleito
presidente naquele ano eu fiz parte de
uma outra instância
e nessa outra instância eu ajudava
outras empresas - com esse mesmo com
esse mesmo treinamento de cultura
organizacional liderança foram mais de
três treinamentos foram mais de 250
pessoas que eu ajudei
e foi exatamente nisso formação de
líderes autênticos passou um tempo
fundei a minha própria empresa continue
a mesma o mesmo princípio um grande
pilar formação de líderes autênticos
porque eu acredito que cada um aqui tem
o potencial de se tornar um líder
o problema é que a gente fica tentando
seguir cinco passos para o sucesso
5 não sei o que passa os modelos
receitas pessoas sendo que na maioria
das vezes a resposta tá dentro de vocês
às vezes a gente só fica com medo de
olhar pra dentro e desafiar essa pessoa
da minha liderança real
o líder real é aquele que transforma em
realidade
esse sim faz grande diferença
se mesmo assim você se duvidarem disso
tudo que eu falei porque vocês mesmo
tempo obrigado
[Aplausos]